More civilian
casualties to
report following a Russian
missile attacks overnight.
At least three lives
lost in southern city of Odessa
and another three killed
in the eastern Donetsk region.
Meanwhile, the Ukrainian military
is claiming further territorial gains
in separate area.
And that's what we find.
Fred Pleitgen.
Fred, I believe he's been spending time
with some of the troops
on the front line.
How are they doing in house morale?
Hi there, Julia.
Well,
it certainly is going for the
for the Ukrainians.
They are saying that
they are making
territorial gains on some places
in the front lines, specifically
the area where we were
where they said
that they managed to take back
a couple of villages there.
But they also say that
the going is extremely tough.
They're able to move forward.
But the Russians are putting up
massive and very stiff resistance
using artillery
and using combat jets as well.
Here's what we witnessed.
Ukrainian forces firing
at Russian troops
holed up in block Adana in south Ukraine.
This video, the brigade
says,
shows the Russians
making a final stand here.
Much of the area near the front lines
deeply scarred by combat.
This is the area of Ukraine
where the heaviest fighting
is currently taking place.
And you can see what it's done
to a lot of the buildings in these cities
and villages around this area.
And that fighting is set to get
even worse
We're with the 68th Yeager Brigade,
which has been making important
gains here.
The soldiers
confident and grateful for U.S.
supply gear
but a lot of the times
it's saved my life, he says.
It saves our lives
every day from shrapnel,
shelling and bullets.
But some of the
vehicles have already been lost,
and the Russians continue to fire back
constant artillery shelling
and even airstrikes too close for comfort
as our crew had to duck for cover
Still, the deputy brigade
commander says his soldiers
are just getting started.
our counterattack
will definitely be successful, he says.
We believe in victory.
We are moving forward towards our goal.
We are advancing
on this part of the frontline.
The Ukrainians believe
they have the gear.
The manpower and the determination
to advance
far into Russian held territory.
So as you can see, Julia,
some pretty tough battles
that are going on there
on that southern front
and in southeastern Ukraine.
And of course, we were only on
one small part of that front.
It really is several hundred miles long.
And there are areas,
of course, where the going is
even tougher
for the Ukrainians, where late last week
the Russians claimed to have shot down
a lot of Western supplied armor.
They're also putting out some videos.
So the going is definitely tough
for the Ukrainians.
But what really stood out to us,
Julia, was the fact
that morale was very high
among those Ukrainian soldiers,
especially after
they've been able
to make those initial gains.
And those gains are very important.
They go pretty deep into the territory
that has been held by the Russians.
But I think that the Ukrainians
also very much understand
that the going is only going
to get tougher from here on.
The Russians have very strong
layers, defenses in the hinterland.
Those go on for a very large part
or for a very long distance.
And the Ukrainians know that the Russians
have some pretty tough soldiers
down there on the ground as well.
So nobody expecting that this offensive
is going to be quick,
that it's going to be short
or that it's going to be easy.
In fact,
the Ukrainians say they understand
if anything, things are going to be long
and things are going to get even tougher
than they already are.
Julia Yeah, they're prepared.
Fred, good to have you.
Thank you. Fred Pleitgen there.
Partial success.
Those are the words
Ukraine is using today
to describe intense ground
fighting in the opening phase
of its summer counteroffensive.
Advances are reported in Bermuda
and separately.
By all accounts,
fighting has been intense.
And these battles are happening
amid increasing air attacks by Russia.
Ukraine says missile
strikes killed three people in Odessa.
And three others in the Donetsk region.
I want to bring in our senior
international correspondent
Sam Collier joins us now live from Kiev.
Good to have you with us.
So let's start
with this summit counteroffensive
certainly underway.
Talk to us about where the efforts
are focused right now.
Well, I think the main
new effort,
if you like, is on that
front line in
is Aparicio
basically about halfway
between Zachary's city and Donetsk
the latter, of course, held by
Russian backed separatists
since 20, 14, 15.
So in that context,
this is a very important
front line
indeed from the Russian perspective
because it is the defensive line
against possible
Ukrainian advances
towards relief of the Crimean peninsula.
It's also
captured by Russia back in 2014.
But the Ukrainians initially began
with their results there in a rather
low level
a series of reconnaissance raids
reconnaissance by forces
is known in the military right now.
It's stepped up its actions
in a significant way.
It's still not a kind of blitzkrieg
it's not the massive assault
that many people were anticipating.
They're still
making very small incremental gains here
and there.
They are taking significant casualties
of the scale of those casualties,
of course, remain a military secret.
But we have seen evidence
that they've lost
some of the NATO's equipment,
inevitably, that they were going
that they were given
to use in this counteroffensive.
But, Linda, at the same time,
they are enjoying success
and gaining momentum
in a salient of territory
south of the city of Parma.
Now, that puts
the Russian troops
that have been battling there
for more than a year
in a very,
very brutal
and ongoing struggle on the back foot.
That is an important development
because of the way
it will
split the pressure on the Russians
making it difficult
for the Russian commanders
to decide quite
where to invest their troops.
But they do
still have the advantage, the Russians,
in terms of troop
troop numbers, in terms of the fact
that they can dominate the skies
above all.
And it's for that reason
that the Ukrainians are continuing
to make international pleas
for the help
with particularly F-16 aircraft.
There are a number of countries
that are currently agreeing
to have agreed to or even begun
training of pilots on fourth generation
fighter jets.
But they've yet to be seen.
Any of those jets
given are much less deployed here
in Ukraine Linda.
And I'm speaking about additional
military aid the U.S.
has indicated that more aid is coming in
the form of additional armored vehicles.
And this,
of course, comes
as the head of Russia's private
military company has indicated
that his forces
will return to the front lines in August.
What more can you tell us
Well, Yevgeny Prigozhin, the
mercurial leader of the Wagner
mercenary group, has indeed,
as you rightly
say, said that his troops
will be returning to the frontline
in August.
They were fighting in parliament.
Indeed, it was their rotation
out in the rotation
of other regular Army groups,
and that coincided with this Ukrainian
push and advances.
But crucially,
he has said
that he will not allow his troops,
as others have agreed to do,
in other militias
and other private military companies
to sign contracts with Russia's
Ministry of Defense,
an organization that he has very loud
and very public contempt for.
How that resolves itself,
I think we'll see play out
over the next few weeks.
But he has said he would
return to the fray.
So that,
I suppose, from the Russian perspective,
might be a good thing.
Although
his men and his behavior often undermines
the leadership structures, there
for Ukraine.
Linda,
Sam Kiley for us in Kiev, Ukraine,
good to have you across
all those developments. Thanks so much.